where he was disgusted at the news
coverage immediately following the death
of Jovan Belcher as I was Belcher was a
linebacker for the Kansas City Chiefs
who shot his girlfriend and mother of
his three-month-old daughter dead after
an early morning argument Belcher then
drove to the Arrowhead Stadium practice
facility to profusely thanked general
manager Scott Pioli and head coach Romeo
Crennel for their roles in his career he
reportedly said I love you bro before
shooting himself fans and sports writers
tried to make sense of the Belcher
violence and with suicide of san diego
charger jr. sale earlier this year in
mine they grasped at common straws that
might tie these two acts together but
what separates Belcher from sales and
other depressed athletes who've
struggled with the fallout from a career
of hard hits and head injuries is that
juniors flight didn't end in the
barbaric murder of his girlfriend and
the orphan another three month old baby
jovan belcher suicide might have forced
the question as to whether or not
football has become too violent and
punishing for its players but killing
his girlfriend elevates the action to
something that cannot be justified by
appeals to celebrity culture or pop
psychology or even readily explained by
scientific research suggesting traumatic
brain injury causes permanent brain
damage and behavioral problems killing
your girlfriend is not a behavioral
problem it is a horrific evil cowardly
act that is morally wrong to try to
either explain or excuse through the
science of batter brains yet everyone
seems to want to blame Belcher's actions
on something else at CNN former
Democratic congressional candidate and
real-world participant Kevin Powell
talked about the problems of super macho
culture and the ready availability of
guns Bob Costas has always been a
broadcasting hero
I've always enjoyed his ability to sum
up and human eyes athletic achievement
and ways both clever and poignant but
Costas lost his nut when he turned the
jovan belcher tragedy into an anti-gun
ramp Costas has fallen further off the
rails than Powell if he thinks a
gun-free belcher home would have also
shown an absence of violence or murder
instead of immediately reaching for our
nearest ideological hobbyhorse let's
stipulate an ugly truth sometimes people
are bad brain injury did not pull the
trigger the blue way both of the zoe
vultures parents one horrible saturday
morning jovan belcher did and for that
he will rightly be remembered not as a
big man but as a bad man for recent TV
I'm Kennedy